Dear Dr. Cutters, the gastro-doctor has recommended for by 71-year-old husband to have an endoscopy.
What would the risk be for such a test and also are there risks and possible solutions to counteract any possible sedation given?
So there's risks with most tests, right?
So again, you have to look at any test that you do, you have to look at is the reward outweigh the risk.
So why would a person do an endoscopy?
They're having upper GI symptoms.
So they're having possible issues is suspected that the person may have a space occupied lesion in the osophagus, in the stomach, in the duodenum, the first part of the small intestine, if they're in suspect that they have an ulcer formation.
So there's different reasons why this person should get the test.
There's that's a great test to be able to visualize different things they could take biopsy during the test of tissue that looks suspect.
It's a good test to do if the person's having problems.
Are there negatives? Well, there's any there's there's negatives to every test, but so is there negatives to having to use sedation?
Well, sure, you could have sensitivity to sense to sedation medication.
Again, like any medication you have to detoxify that medication afterwards.
So what would you do to help with that? You just support the liver detox pathways post treatment.
You wouldn't necessarily increase liver detoxification support prior to treatment because you wouldn't have to require more sedation.
If you have more active phase two, phase one, two, three pathways in the liver.
I'd say after the, the, the procedure that you could support phase one, two, three.
Well, she's just poured all your detoxification pathways really. So it's just like when people ask me, okay, should I do a CT scan?
You know, we have cancer patients. Should I do a CT scan? Should I do a PET scan? What's the pros and cons to that?
Well, you do it to satisfy the need for, you know, to find out what's going on to get a better diagnostic picture.
And I always recommend with any invasive test.
So is, well, CT scans are not invasive. They don't cut any open. Well, it's invasive because you're getting radiation exposure.
Same with PET scans, same, you know, people cancer patients may be concerned with the glucose solution that you have to consume prior to the PET scan.
And MRI is less invasive, isn't it? Well, usually it's with a contrast die.
So usually you are exposed to Galileo. So there's issues with that. So there's invasiveness with any test that you have.
So you have to weigh out that level of invasive this, the dangers that that is going to happen to the benefits of the test. And I always recommend that you only run a test to if it's going to change the way you treat the patient.
So you don't, it's not always beneficial to run, just run a PET scan, just to see, you know, are you doing better?
Unless it's going to change the way I treat the patient or the patient's perspective, you do a test.
If it's going to change the way you're going to choose whatever treatment plan, depending upon what comes out in that test.
So yes, should you do a CT scan on a patient who has a history of cancer, if I don't if they're spread of the cancer?
Well, if it's going to change the way you as the patient are going to then approach treatment, then yes, I would agree to that test.
Meaning that if it comes back where I am, maybe the test is to bold, let's say, are you going to treat it differently?
If the answer is yes, then maybe you should go ahead with that test. If the answer is no, I'm not going to do anything different. I'm going to keep doing everything that I'm doing right now.
Well, then why are you going to, you know, put yourself in a position where you could have negative effects from the procedure itself?
So those are the things that you decisions that you make in as a doctor in suggesting a test.
And decisions you make as a patient, whether you should agree to a test, is it going to change the way I treat myself?
So in the case of endoscopy, if the doctor saying I really feel like he could have this, that you could have it also.
So I'd like to go ahead and look at that.
Is it going to change the way you treat it? Well, to get a diagnostic picture, maybe it will. Maybe it won't. Maybe you're going to say, no, I'm just going to treat it with natural methods.
And such anyhow, well, then maybe you should just go that route first and maybe if your symptoms clear up and other tests that are less invasive like blood work clears up, then you don't decide to move forward with that.
So those are the decision making processes that you have to make when you're doing any type of invasive testing.